hello Hong Kong thanks for hanging
around I will try to deliver so one
thing I've been thinking a lot about as
I've been spending time walking the
conference hall and spending the day
today in Hong Kong is just the diversity
in the audience of where we come from
what we're trying to achieve and I gave
a lot of thought to what do I really
want to deliver in this keynote how do I
bring value I think one of the things
that you know when I think about
products or services and definitely when
I speak or create content how do you
bring value like what's the trade here
I'm getting your attention I want to
bring you value in return and the thing
that really stands out for me is the one
thing that I'm confident in the one
thing that I'm absolutely confident in
is what attaches all of us what is the
one common theme whether you're a
startup whether you're a professional
with your student solo entrepreneur
large company starting tomorrow what is
the one thing that guarantees a
connection point that we can all agree
on and get value out of the framework
that I create here and I think that
comes down to one simple thing that no
matter what you're doing in this room
whether you're trying to raise money for
a non-profit or you're trying to sell a
syntek product or trying to raise
capital for what you're trying to
achieve the one thing that we all trade
on in this room is attention the thing
that allows me the luxury to stand here
in front of you guys today is that I
have had a very successful career over
the last 20 years on trading attention
basically all I ever think about is your
attention where is it and how do I
create content there to drive whatever
I'm trying to achieve so when I think
about the connection point for this
audience it's predicated on attention
where are the eyeballs where are the
ears where are they and how do you trade
on them now the way
we trade in the environment we live on
today is this is it like anybody who
doesn't understand that this is the
single most important thing on earth
besides your health is making enormous
enormous mistakes now obviously that's a
hyperbolized statement but if you want
to be relevant if you're sitting in this
conference right now and this is not
your religion you're in deep [ __ ] and
you're in deep [ __ ] because every second
that goes by whatever the consumers
attention was on it is going here and
will there be a day when this goes away
absolutely but for now it all comes down
to trading attention in the reality of
the moment we're in and that reality
sits on that device and it sits on
platforms that have been able to become
layers on top of that device and in
every country whether it's mainland
China versus Russia versus the u.s.
versus Indonesia every country is going
to have its dynamics of which three to
seven to nine platforms were able to
penetrate and layer themselves on top of
here and then once that is established
it is everybody's job in here to produce
stories whether in whren audio or video
form to be in those platforms to
basically tell your story and you need
to basically explain to me the value
prop of what you're bringing to the
table in that environment and the big
vulnerability is if you've been a
marketer or operator or entrepreneur for
the last 20 years like I have the [ __ ]
changes in 1996-1997 in the US market I
created an e-commerce wine business that
was smart because other wine stores
weren't doing it then there was this
thing called email and I had how many
people here have done email or do email
marketing for their business raise your
hand high raise high don't be shy great
so for some of us that have been doing
it for a little bit longer in 1997 I had
90 percent open rates on a 200 thousand
person email newsletter
it wasn't because the email was so
incredible all I wanted to do was sell
you Bordeaux it was that nobody else was
doing it and so the attention arbitrage
was in my favor if you read email in the
late 90s there's a lot of youngsters
here if you read email in 1997 you read
them all and so that was my first foray
in getting an arbitrage then Google
AdWords came out and I bought every wine
term on Google for five cents a click
and Google AdWords were grossly
underpriced the market underpriced the
attention of people searching for
products on Google or services or
information and I was able to make an
arbitrage there and then it was YouTube
and then it was Twitter and then it was
Facebook and an Instagram and it done
punchline being very simple if you are
not sitting and debating on an everyday
basis on how you as a human or as a
company act like a modern day media
publisher how you communicate whether in
written audio or video form and then
which platforms are under priced and
overpriced you're basing missing the
punchline
it doesn't matter how good bad or
indifferent your products or services if
nobody knows about it
you are vulnerable and the thing that
I'm curious about is where everybody in
this room is on their lifecycle because
if you've had success for three or four
years you might have fallen in love with
what got you here the biggest concern I
have and I see some heads nodding
already is what god you hear today is
always the thing that's not going to get
you to tomorrow the problem is for
anybody that's had any level of success
you become very romantic and you fall in
love with the maneuver that got you here
and so I have been fascinated and now as
I project the next two decades it's
fascinating how quickly our attention
shifts for example for me if you ask me
today
what am I most paying attention to where
do I see the next arbic
it's absolutely around audio I am
obsessed with what's going in the US
market not only around podcasts and this
is global but especially around what's
going on with Alexa from Amazon Google
home and the future Apple home pod when
you think about sound you know one of
the great mistakes of my career was
passing on the uber angel round at four
million dollar valuation twice when I
later invested when it was a 50 million
dollar valuation the reason I invested
was not because I saw anything other
than I realized that uber was selling
time not transportation the one thing I
promise you is that every single person
here besides the health and well-being
of their family and money values time
and time is emerging very quickly if you
take a look and this is extremely
prevalent through the Asian market
European markets South American market
US market x value is exceeding on an
everyday basis as we become more busy we
start valuing time tremendously
tremendously that is what uber and other
transportation apps have traded on it's
saving you time even the perception of
time is a good business model but the
thing that I think I'm very fascinated
by is how much sound and audio will be
selling back to you time founded that
you used to not have when you watch a
video which I think we can all agree
video content is scaling and importance
that is absolutely in the prime of its
medium right now when you're looking at
video it is taking up your time audio is
incredibly passive and you are able to
multitask the other thing that is
extremely fascinating to me is the first
five to seven minutes of every person
hears morning and when I think about the
potential of sound devices interacting
with us and giving us our briefings or
our 10 things we need to know the reason
I choose rise Hong Kong crowd the reason
I chose to focus on sound right away is
I
obsessed with figuring out how do I
bring value while I stand up here today
I'm aware and see very early clear
indications by consumer behavior that no
matter what's going on with your
business now whether you are the leader
or you are somebody who's trying to win
marketplace the great flaw of so many
businesses and individuals here is they
spend so much time trying to catch up in
the current game they don't spend enough
time anticipating the next game and
being a first mover one of the great
things about the era of social media is
if you sucked at YouTube or Facebook
inevitably snapchat and Instagram are
coming next it's the great thing it's
the terrible thing it sucks having a 20
year career where you've been write a
lot and you know that it only lasts for
a little bit and that something will
emerge that you have to be right about
again because you will be armed out of
your leadership role because the
attention of our consumer will shift
it's exciting because you always know
that if you struggled with the current
landscape you have another chance in 24
or 36 months as our attention continues
to shift what is always true and forever
true is that quality content will always
have a competitive advantage what is
completely misunderstood is you don't
get to be the judge of quality content
the audacity of the media or thought
leaders or successful individuals or
just a person that they get to judge
what is quality content has been the
opening that so many people can take
advantage of content is subjective the
market decides what's good and bad not
you pondering what's good and bad over a
beer with your best friends so we need
to spend a lot less time debating
quality and we need to start thinking a
lot more about clear indicators that
quantity and distribution really really
matter if you were an artist that
produces music
it is now only practical to produce a
new song every week and put it on
soundcloud and spotify on every platform
that you can and so the thing that I'm
trying to force down energy-wise
in this keynote is the following number
one no matter what you do for a living
you need to think of yourself as a media
company your company if you were a SAS
tech you are a media company comma SAS
tech if you are a consumer social
network you are a media company comma
social network if you are a human being
you are a media company comma human
being when you wrap your head around
that you start understanding what you
should be doing which is in your natural
way producing stories for people to
consume to bring awareness to what you
do let me explain
number one you have to figure out which
medium / indexes for you so many people
are trying to be something that they
think is emerging like a deal guys dear
hard it is to live stream and keep
people's attention like it is difficult
to be good enough on live video that's
worth watching and keeping people there
that takes an enormous amount of skill
so instead of worrying that video is
emerging because nobody nobody 36 months
ago said you know what's going to get
cool again radio nobody saw serial or
podcast emerging at the level globally
that we've seen so one thing I can
promise you is nothing new is going to
happen the same mediums of communication
which are the framework to awareness to
any product/service movement or anything
else will always stay the same what you
need to do and your organization need to
do is figure out are you a writer
are you a voice are you a video producer
and then really start focusing on that
and the contextual platforms that allow
you to distribute that message this is
the game and this game is not changing
this game will not change when we go
into an augmented virtual reality world
this game will not change this is Hugh
communication the people that drew the
best pictures in caves won the guy who
did the best smoke signals on a [ __ ]
mountain one and it's tried and true
over and over again the only thing that
changes is the mediums and the thing
that everybody has to focus on is not
content
everybody talks about content is king
meanwhile everybody is missing that
context is the queen and she runs the
[ __ ] household and what we are not
doing is respecting context enough in
the current landscape of communication
and that is where the magic sits I have
been able to over index when I audited
leases that are able to over index they
are respecting the context they don't
dismiss hashtags
they don't dismiss filters they don't
dismiss the nuance of how long is the
read on medium
they don't dismiss the first three
seconds of a YouTube video they don't
dismiss they don't dismiss they don't
dismiss I see a Facebook post I see a
post I analyze every piece of word in
the copy the screenshot that is the
default the engagement all of it all of
it matters and communication is what
brings awareness to what you have the
best way to sell my friends is to have
it come to you the best way to have it
come to you is to produce something that
is relevant to your audience and
understand how to distribute it and so
that is the punchline I mean I'm going
to be raw for a few minutes I'll come
back to it but I want to try to check a
couple of boxes here while I'm here I
want to speak to the how many people
here are entrepreneurs and run their own
business raise your hands perfect I want
to speak about this for a second I think
there's a couple things I'd love you
know one man's point of view just a
couple of random thoughts number one one
more time entrepreneurs we have it so
good this is the greatest era of
entrepreneurship ever I want you to
realize how grateful you should be
because your grandparents and your
great-grandparents didn't
have it this good the practicality of
what the guys we are under estimating
the Internet to a level that would blow
your mind off the internet is the
greatest thing that has ever happened to
the human race people will be
pessimistic about it but this is an
incredible change about how many people
in this room remember the world
pre-internet raise your hand
shit's crazy right like for the ones
that don't you can't even wrap your head
around how big of a shift this is so
number one to every entrepreneur here
your great grandmother wanted to be an
entrepreneur - but it wasn't practical
because she had to pay the bills and do
her thing and she couldn't work on it at
9:00 p.m. at night so how the world
worked someone if you are not taking
this opportunity for what it is
you've already already put yourself in
second place this is the moment number
two entrepreneurship got popular and
that means it's dangerous because
there's a lot of people that raise your
hands that have entrepreneurial
tendencies and aren't necessarily
entrepreneurs just because you say
you're an entrepreneur doesn't mean your
next successful entrepreneur and I the
reason I bring that up is not to be like
I'm cool you're now or anything of that
nature there's just one very important
thing that is not being discussed enough
we talked about working smart and having
the right strategy and having the right
product I'm stunned by how much pushback
there is when I talk about working hard
there is no zero people you know that
have built a successful business without
working their face off there are people
that have inherited money there are
people that have had that dynamic but
you know nobody nor does the world that
has started from zero and build
something substantial that hasn't put in
a disproportional amount of work to get
there it is the one uh turley
controllable aspect of our game and if
you really want this please really start
thinking about maximizing every minute
that doesn't mean neglecting your fan
Emily that doesn't mean neglecting your
health but I am stunned as somebody
who's spending an enormous amount of
time in this ecosystem by how many
people have the ambition and their mouth
is running to what they're going to
accomplish and their actions don't map
to it at all
and so I please I beg you to realize how
lucky you are to be in the game during a
time where there's so much
infrastructure that gives us a great
chance to make it practical and I just
want to remind everybody the global
economy has been really good for a while
now for some of the other people in this
room that remember the world
pre-internet the good times don't last
forever
this [ __ ] conference existed in 2000
and everybody got a job after [ __ ] hit
the fan so please take advantage and go
hard because when [ __ ] hits the fan and
there's no funding and you run out of
money and you have to go work at UBS you
would have wished that you would have
worked [ __ ] harder during this era
what else that's the big one may have
[ __ ] hype you know it's funny I
appreciate that one you know it's just
really practical like when it's good and
when you have it on your side it's
important to squeeze as hard and as fast
as you can because it's hard to get to
the other side and there's you know when
I look around this room there's so many
youngsters if you've never tasted the
shitty era if you weren't operating in
2008 and nine if you weren't operating
in year 2000 you just don't know it's
not your fault this is the landscape
that you've worked on this has been the
environment for the last eight or nine
years it's very difficult to know what
the alternatives look like let me help
you what the alternatives look like your
[ __ ] idea is now worth four million
dollars right you don't just your be
round isn't guys I invested in tumblr in
2009 in its be round at a 14 million
dollar valuation you know it's a
different landscape and it takes real
skill to navigate through those times so
you have to take advantage of it right
now a couple of things that I'm really
paying attention to
the things that I am passionate about
being underpriced which are social
networks that have true marketplace ad
platforms so let me say it carefully
because I know we a lot of us play in
different markets if you have a social
network at scale where all of the
pricing of the ad inventory is based on
supply and demand market dynamics the
Facebook's and the googles and the
things of their world the thing that I
want a lot of the startups and
entrepreneurs to understand here is the
following the fortune 1000 the 5,000
biggest companies in the world are
grossly under spending on these
platforms they are grossly under
spending on these platforms as somebody
who lived through the word whine being
five cents a click and then being nine
dollars let me explain to you what's
going to happen over the next 36 to 48
months as these companies wake up and
realize they're pouring good money down
the trash on television commercials and
billboards and all this other horseshit
in a 20-18 environment they're going to
take that money and they're going to
move it to these market places and the
cost of you penetrating the end
consumers attention will grossly excel
in cost deeming them less of a good deal
than they are today there will be a day
when I go to [ __ ] rise or Web Summit
order [ __ ] Patti tells me to go there
will be a day where I stand right here
and I will say you're still doing social
networks you're an idiot not because of
anything other than two dynamics will
happen number one we will be more
conditioned to see dynamics and start
tuning out the ads and number two the
proper level of investment from the
biggest companies in the world will go
there deeming the platform appropriately
priced not under priced once you put
your hole in where the water's coming
out somewhere else will emerge for me as
a Russian immigrant who had a family
business we didn't have a lot of money i
$13,000 an advertising budget for the
entire year
every penny mattered and that's why I
found myself to email in Google Adwords
if I had millions of dollars I would
have bought the Wall Street Journal and
television commercials and all that
other horseshit this dynamic for this
room matters tremendously because we are
sitting right now in the last 20 years
in one of the great arbitrage moments
right now these social networks at scale
with market dynamic prices are grossly
underpriced and number two and even more
extremely under price depending on the
market we are living through the great
boom of the early influencer marketing
dynamics where influencers are so under
priced after you take away the top 1%
that 99% of influencers or Kol s or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call them
are so grossly underpriced right now
that everybody will look back to this 5
to 7 year era and be sad that they'd
import more money into that price point
into that ecosystem and so for me as I
sit here today I get excited because I
know the people that act on these
arbitrage errs are going to
disproportionately win one thing that
has never talked about and will be in
the history books is how much amazon
used google adwords to build their
business one thing that is long
forgotten is how much ebay used google
adwords to build their business we have
these moments and you need to take
advantage of that and so I implore you
that if you're still just headline
reading and you've made your decision on
the ROI of WeChat or Facebook or
snapchat or whatever may be that you get
educated because the amount of people in
this room that are headline readers and
are not practitioners is stunning we are
in a complete ecosystem right now of
headline readers who read one or two
three things and they form their
opinions a lot of people here tonight
over a glass of wine are going to debate
the value of something that they've
never executed on and in that in that
human vulnerability where you only
headline read and you
talk about [ __ ] you don't know is the
arbitrage so the current ARB social
network marketplace dynamics influencers
my intuition on the emerging arbitrage
voice between podcasting and skill based
AI voice dynamics super interesting
other than that all overpriced [ __ ]
we've got billions of dollars being
poured into 30-second commercials that
nobody's watching we've got billions of
dollars being poured into programmatic
banner and pre-roll inventory that
nobody gives a [ __ ] about and so we have
a big disconnect which means when you
have such a dynamic you have the biggest
companies in the world wasting their
money this is when the opportunity for
emergence is and so we live through
these times with these dynamics and play
while at the same time both of the US
and China we have an incredibly
interesting moment that is an absolute
fear for a lot of entrepreneurs which is
the big incumbents have never been
quicker to copy features to not allow
startups to gain momentum and what you
see in China and definitely in the US
with Facebook and Instagram is now
starting to bleed into the b2b
environment and clearly into the b2c
environment so we have an era right now
where the vulnerability of a land grab
of consumers and attention is a
difficult one if the incumbent leaders
are viewing your business as a feature
versus an actual business now to me
that's exactly how it should be this
notion that Facebook should have sat
around and let's snapchat grow is
laughable there's never been a time when
a competitor goes oh that's nice and had
very little cost to compete with it and
they let it happen this romantic point
of view from a creative or a product
standpoint will no longer be in play in
our ecosystem so as you navigate your
product and service you've got to live
under the dynamics that
the cat is now out of the bag and that
you have to move even quicker to
penetrate your market that ever belong
and so we live through an era right now
where speed is no question the variable
of success and that's why I'm going to
end with the following the most
important thing for speed for your
company and your service is your
internal culture the number one thing
that will make your company go fast is
continuity and lack of politics which
means we are on the dawn of the era
where emotional intelligence is about to
become the single most important trade
that skills through technology growth
will continue on a daily basis to be
commoditized but your emotional
capabilities to interact with others
will become very very important trade I
highly recommend how many people here
have a company with more than 10 people
raise your hands I highly highly highly
recommend that if you take anything away
from my talk suck voice 5 suck in
arbitrage take this one thing away from
me
you better go home and audit every
single employee you have and you better
figure out which employee makes the
other employees miserable I don't give a
[ __ ] if it's your number one salesperson
your best [ __ ] developer or your
co-founder cancer spreads with cancer
and politics comes lack of speed your
company will get much slower because
people are sitting around debating how
miserable they are or worried to have
meetings with other individuals your
company will get slow in a world where
the speed of product output features and
how you interact with your customers has
never been greater so I implore a tech
centric financial centric type a room
like this to go home and get really in
tune with their [ __ ] feelings in my
company the number 2 person is not the
CFO or the CEO
a CEO excuse me the number two person
after me
is Claude silver she is the chief heart
officer she's a head of HR call it what
you want it is no question the biggest
variable to our success
it is never and I mean ever been more
important for you to care about the
internal feelings culture let me tell
you how you do not build culture you do
not build culture by having free snacks
in your cafeteria let me tell you how
you do not build culture you do not
build culture by having a foosball table
or open seating you build culture by
actually talking to people one by one
and understanding what they care about
and what you learn is some people want
money and some people want time with
their family and some people want title
and some people want creativity and it
is your job how many people to see over
the company it is your job to know every
single one of those things about every
single person every single day because
23 year old Sally at 27 wants different
[ __ ] 31 year old Charlie at 34 wants a
different [ __ ] it is time that this
ecosystem starts paying attention to the
human elements that will drive our
businesses to the next level this is a
conversation we are not having and it is
the conversation in the next decade
thank you
[Applause]